dernier chapitre de l'actualité
l'actualité sportive une grande aventure
a commencé ce matin pour cent soixante
seize pilotes d'autos et de motos qui
ont quitté paris pour dakar 8500 km d'un
rallye qui leur fera traverser l'algérie
le mali le niger et le sénégal
cent soixante seize concurrents donc
dont la moitié en moto les deux roues
sont d'ailleurs favori avec surtout
christian de noyer champion de france de
trial du côté des voitures jacky privé
et cyril neveu ont remarquablement
préparé ce paris dakar et ils seront
sans doute bien placés en tout cas la
difficulté de cette épreuve rend tout
pronostic particulièrement hasardeuse
nous parlerons souvent de ce paris dakar
dans notre journal
car une équipe de tf1 avec jean pierre
chapel et jean-françois dunac tente
l'aventuré et nous fera vivre au fur et
à mesure le déroulement de cette course